in der Gastronomie im Handwerk überall
fehlen Arbeitskräfte wenn auch noch die
Boomer in Rente gehen werden wir alle
mehr arbeiten müssen meint der Direktor
des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft wir werden uns fragen müssen
warum wir in Deutschland mit geringsten
Arbeitszeiten in der Welt haben das
schweizerniveau könnte möglicherweise
eine orientierungsmarke für Deutschland
sein in der Schweiz sind bis zu 42,5
Stunden Arbeitszeit pro Woche normal die
Stunden Woche vor 40 Jahren hart
erkämpft könnte bald Geschichte sein
hütters Institut hat errechnet dass bis
2030 bis zu 5 Millionen Arbeitskräfte
fehlen Arbeitsmarkt als Dauerbaustelle
und Gewerkschaftler auf der Suche nach
neuen Ideen sind wirklich ganz viele
Veränderungen als dass der
Arbeitskräftemangel in vielen
Dienstleistungsbranchen zumindestens Fuß
fast im öffentlichen Dienst genauso in
den privaten
Dienstleistungsbranchen tausende von
Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst nicht
besetzt sind im Gesundheitswesen an den
Kitas dramatische Zustände aber auch in
vielen privaten Bereichen das verändert
natürlich schon auch die
Kräfteverhältnisse in der Arbeitswelt
oder anders ausgedrückt der Wert der
wahre Arbeit steigt sitzen Arbeitnehmer
bald am längeren Hebel werden sie mehr
Geld und bessere Rahmenbedingungen
fordern in Unternehmerkreisen geht die
Angst um und die wohlfeile Behauptung
die Generation Set wolle gar nicht
arbeiten die K Nann ist genervt von
solchen Vorurteilen gegen die Jugend und
hält
dagegen wir reden nicht mal dass das
eigentlich interessant ist wer die
wirklichen faulen sind die vielleicht
auf Kosten des Systems sich sich
ausruhen auf jeden Fall s nicht die
Jugendlichen also die haben Lust die
wollen ihr Leben gestalten ich finde man
kann niemand die haben auch gerade eine
Pandemie hinter sich global gesehen ist
es sowieso auch schwierig also ich finde
es ziemlich klasse wie die damit umgehen
gerade davon erzählt sie auch in ihrem
Buch ihre Leser sollen fordern wählen
was sie machen wollen und für wen
narimann will die Qualität von Arbeit
verbessern die Zufriedenheit der
Arbeitnehmer vergrößern für manche
Wirtschaftsforscher sind das
Traumschlösser bis 2030 fehlen uns über
3 Millionen Erwerbspersonen rein
alterungsbedingt und es fehlen 4,2
Milliarden Arbeitsstunden wollte man das
Ausgleichen müsste
beispielsweise jeder im Land tätige 100
Stunden mehr im Jahr arbeiten letzter
Ausweg Überstunden klingt eher nach
Arbeitswelt von gestern als von morgen
denn nun sind auch die Arbeitgeber in
der Bringschuld findet zumindest die
Unternehmensberaterin Ronja Ebeling sie
hat für ihr Buch den Spieß einmal
umgedreht und die Arbeitgeber zum
Vorstellungsgespräch gebeten und wie aus
ihrer Sicht die Arbeitswelt von morgen
aussehen könnte erklärt sie hier einer
Netzwerkerin aus Frankfurt meiner
Generation wird dann ja häufig
vorgeworfen ihr müsst mehr arbeiten
damit wir uns den Wohlstand in
Deutschland sichern können was in meinen
Augen totaler Quatsch ist denn wenn uns
so viele Arbeitskräfte in Zukunft fehlen
dann können wir nicht noch mehr
Überstunden machen also im letzten Jahr
wurden 700 Millionen unbezahlte
Überstunden gemacht was ist denn die
Anspruchshaltung dass man meiner
Generation sagt ihr müsst noch mehr
Überstunden machen nee vielleicht müssen
wir dann einfach unsere Strukturen oder
auch die Produkte die Geschäftsmodelle
verändern damit das funktioniert na ja
vielleicht steckt da auch Angst drin
dass wir nur das Geschäfts und
Wirtschaftsmodell können was bis jetzt
immer gefahren haben aber eigentlich ist
ja Innovation der Punkt der den Rahmen
für eine Zukunft liefert eine innovative
Idee schwebt über der Debatte die vier
Tage Woche weniger arbeiten und trotzdem
gleich viel verdienen eine Studie in
England hat gezeigt das geht jetzt soll
das auch in Deutschland erforscht werden
und ein Betrieb in Thüringen macht mit
hier haben sie die vier Tage Woche
längst eingeführt mit
Erfolg gehum Arbeitswelt zu verändern
und mehrere Dinge anzubieten und zu
durchleuchten und in der Studie geht es
auch darum wie verändert also eine
andere Arbeitswelt ein anderes
miteinander ein anderes
Verantwortungsbewusstsein ein ja eine
neue unternehmsführung das ist der
Schlüssel zu allen Dingen also unter
demem was über das was wir hier gemacht
haben kann man schreiben und das meine
ich tatsächlich so der alte Chef muss
weg der Boss von früher nun einer unter
gleichen die Verantwortung wird auf
viele Schultern verteilt das motiviert
die Mitarbeiter ein wichtiger Baustein
aber ist die Digitalisierung der Betrieb
ist komplett vernetzt alle Geräte und
Werkzeuge wurden mit QR-Codes erfasst
suchen war früher keiner vertut mehr
seine Zeit und die wird effektiver
genutzt als Quereinsteiger kam der
Industriekaufmann Kevin Hoffmann zum
eichfelder leckortungs und
bautrocknungsservice ich muss meinen Tag
selber planen ich bin dafür
verantwortlich mit dafür verantwortlich
dass die vier Tage Woche zustande kommt
dass wir das am Leben erhalten können
und das funktioniert natürlich nur durch
effektive Ausnutzung der Arbeitszeit die
neue Studie soll zeigen ob die echte
vier tageewoche funktioniert die
Zauberformel weniger Arbeitszeit und
trotzdem produktiv und kostendeckend
ruft viele Zweifler auf den Plan die
Produktivität fällt nicht vom Himmel
auch nur wenn wir uns das wünschen und
es ist ja sehr auffällig dass gerade in
dieser Zeit manche hoffen es gibt es die
großen rationalisier
uns die Arbeitszeit frei
wirtschaftshistorisch spricht da wenig
dafür die Welten prallen aufeinander
wenn es um Lösungen für die Probleme auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt geht aber eines
zeichnet sich ab mit alten Rezepten
kommt man den neuen Problemen nicht bei
der alte Boss ist ein Auslaufmodell und
Druck von oben zieht nicht mehr Ronja
Ebeling hält nichts von längeren
Arbeitszeiten und autoritären
Struktur der jungen Generation wird ja
häufig auch ein autoritätsp nachgesagt
ich glaub das ist gar nicht der Fall ich
glaube wir müssen uns einfach eher
überlegen ja was bedeutet Autorität
heute Autorität war sehr lange etwas was
man nicht hinterfragen durfte was oben
war und den Ton angegeben hat und ich
glaube heute müssen wir uns vorstellen
dass Autorität auch etwas fürsorgliches
sein kann und dass Autorität natürlich
auch hinterfragt werden darf der Wandel
der Arbeitswelt hat keinen Lichtschalter
er braucht Zeit besonders im Kopf